Film Courage: I’m just curious, what were
some common clichés (at that time) which
you were seeing in these scripts?
Daniel Calvisi: Well some big mistakes I would
say that I would get from scripts coming in
the door were big really dense blocks of description,
just too many words on the page.
The worst is when they make the margins really
small so they can fit more on the page because
they haven’t really tightened the script
up enough.
So with making the margins tiny and even the
spacing, you can make tighter in final draft
and in other screenwriting software, if you
do that the [script] reader immediately knows
you are cheating and they know that your script
may say it’s a 110 pages.
But if you went to normal margins and normal
spacing it would probably be like 123 pages
or something.
So readers hate that.
You know right off the bat because you are
taking up more of their time and it also shows
that you’re an undisciplined writer who
doesn’t know how to write a well-paced script
in the proper spacing and format with let’s
say the average script being around 105 to
110 pages these days.
So there is that and then it takes too long
to get to the inciting incident.
The inciting incident should be between page
8 to 10.
Sometimes 12 is okay but we really need a
catalyst, you know?
We need an inciting incident to happen.
And then as well later on you don’t want
Act 1 to be too far into the script.
The break of Act 1 and Act 2 should be probably
around page 30.
It doesn’t have to be exactly on page 30,
but around page 30.
But in some beginner scripts it would literally
be on page 47 before a really big turn in
direction happened and it felt like we were
in Act two.
So those are some examples.
However the on-the-nose dialogue could be
one of the worst.
I like to say sometimes talking heads dialogue
where it’s just two characters talking to
each other (kind of at each other).
And then Q&A sessions are the worst.
That’s where one character keeps asking
another character questions and then they
just keep answering it.
So it’s almost like a interview.
And if that goes on for too long it really
tires out the reader and it gets really what
we call on-the-nose.